Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. Metrolinks and Crosslinks are reminding everyone to be careful, as Eglinton Crosstown LRT train testing is in progress. Please be alert, as trains can pass at any time on the tracks. Remember to follow all traffic signals. Be careful along our tracks, and only make left turns where it's safe to do so.
感谢您收听《历史的余味》（The Rest Is History）。如需每周额外剧集、无广告收听、抢先观看系列节目以及加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请前往 therestishistory.com 加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。Metrolinks 和 Crosslinks 提醒大家注意安全，埃格林顿跨城轻轨（Eglinton Crosstown LRT）列车测试正在进行中。请保持警惕，因为列车随时可能经过轨道。请务必遵守所有交通信号。在轨道沿线请小心谨慎，仅在安全的情况下进行左转。
Be alert, be aware, and stay safe. It happened that in the midst of the dissipations attendant upon a London winter, there appeared at the various parties of the leaders of the ton a nobleman, more remarkable for his singularities than his rank. He gazed upon the mirth around him as if he could not participate therein. Apparently, the light laughter of the fair only attracted his attention, that he might by a look quell it and throw fear into those breasts where thoughtlessness reigned. Those who felt this sensation of awe could not explain whence it arose. Some attributed it to the dead grey eye, which fixing upon the object's face did not seem to penetrate, and at one glance to pierce through
请保持警惕，提高意识，注意安全。在伦敦冬季的各种消遣活动中，社交界的领袖们举办的派对上出现了一位贵族，他因其古怪的性格而非地位而引人注目。他凝视着周围的欢闹，仿佛无法参与其中。显然，名媛们轻快的笑声之所以能吸引他的注意，只是为了让他能用一个眼神将其平息，并让那些思想浅薄的人心中产生恐惧。那些感受到这种敬畏感的人无法解释它从何而来。有些人将其归因于那双死灰色的眼睛，它盯着物体的表面，似乎无法穿透，一眼望去，仿佛能刺穿
to the inward workings of the heart, but fell upon the cheek with a leaden ray that weighed upon the skin it could not pass. His peculiarities caused him to be invited to every house. All wished to see him, and those who had been accustomed to violent excitement and now felt the weight of ennui, were pleased at having something in their presence capable of engaging their attention, in spite of the deadly hue of his face, which never gained a warmer tint, either from the blush of modesty or from the strong emotion of passion. Though its form and outline were beautiful, many of the female hunters after notoriety attempted to win his attentions and gain at least some marks of what they might term affection.
直达心灵的深处，却又带着一种铅灰色的光芒落在脸颊上，压在皮肤上却无法穿透。他的怪癖使他受到每家每户的邀请。所有人都想见他，而那些习惯了强烈刺激、如今感到厌倦的人，很高兴能在身边有这样一个能吸引他们注意力的人，尽管他那张脸呈现出一种死气沉沉的色调，从未因羞涩的红晕或强烈的激情而增添一丝暖意。虽然他的外形和轮廓都很美，但许多追求名声的女性还是试图赢得他的关注，并获得一些她们可能称之为“爱慕”的标志。
So that, Tom, is the opening of a novel called The Vampire, published in 1819. It carried the attribution, a tale by Lord Byron. So listeners can be reassured, it's not one of your own early works. But it has a really interesting backstory, interesting history, this book, doesn't it? Because it's not by Lord Byron. Is that right? It's not. Although you can completely see, listening to that, why people would think that it was by Byron, because it'sently modelled on Byron's years of fame in London. There's a reference to a Lady Mercer who dresses up as a mountebank and throws herself
所以，汤姆，这就是1819年出版的小说《吸血鬼》（The Vampire）的开篇。它署名为“拜伦勋爵（Lord Byron）所著的故事”。所以听众们可以放心，这不是你早期的作品之一。但这本书有一个非常有趣的背景故事，一段有趣的历史，不是吗？因为它并不是拜伦勋爵写的。是这样吗？确实不是。虽然听了这段话，你完全能明白为什么人们会认为它是拜伦写的，因为它显然是以拜伦在伦敦成名那几年的生活为蓝本的。书中提到了默瑟夫人（Lady Mercer），她打扮成江湖郎中，并把自己
in this aristocrat's way. And that's clearly modelled on Caroline Lamb. And what makes that absolutely certain is that the fact that the name of this mysterious Lord, Lord Ruffin, derived from a novel that Caroline Lamb had written in which the hero is called Lord Ruffin, derived from a novel that Caroline Lamb had written, in which the hero is called Lord Ruffin and is clearly Lord Byron. And what makes this all the more intriguing is that Lord Ruffin is a vampire. And in fact, he is the first aristocratic vampire, because until this point, vampires was a kind of Balkan peasant superstition. And Byron had learned about it in the Balkans, as we will see in due course. When this book gets published, it's widely interpreted as a confession, an acknowledgement
投向这位贵族。这显然是以卡罗琳·兰姆（Caroline Lamb）为原型。而让这一点变得绝对确定的是，这位神秘勋爵的名字——鲁芬勋爵（Lord Ruffin），源自卡罗琳·兰姆写的一部小说，书中的英雄就叫鲁芬勋爵，他显然就是拜伦勋爵。而让这一切更引人入胜的是，鲁芬勋爵是一个吸血鬼。事实上，他是第一位贵族吸血鬼，因为在此之前，吸血鬼只是一种巴尔干半岛农民的迷信。正如我们稍后将看到的，拜伦是在巴尔干半岛了解到这一点的。当这本书出版时，它被广泛解读为一种忏悔，一种承认
by Byron that he was indeed guilty of all the terrible sins that people think that he's guilty of. We left him at the end of the previous episode going into exile, and this shadow of the satanic hanging over him. And so people read this book and think, yeah, okay, he's basically fessing up. But as you say, it's not actually by Byron. So just before you say who it is by Tom, just to recap, we left Byron at the end of the last episode. We did the first episode all about his upbringing. Then we had his great travels, meeting with the Sultan, Ali Pasha, falling in love with Greece, being crossed with Lord Elgin. And then the last episode, this absolutely bizarre,
拜伦确实犯下了人们认为他所犯下的所有可怕罪行。上一集结束时，我们让他流亡海外，而这种撒旦般的阴影笼罩着他。所以人们读了这本书，心想，是的，好吧，他基本上是在坦白。但正如你所说，它实际上并不是拜伦写的。所以在你告诉大家作者是谁之前，汤姆，我们先回顾一下，上一集结束时我们讲到了拜伦。我们做了第一集，讲了他的成长经历。然后是他伟大的旅行，会见苏丹、阿里帕夏（Ali Pasha），爱上希腊，与埃尔金勋爵（Lord Elgin）发生冲突。然后是上一集，他在英国那段绝对离奇、
dangerous liaison-style love life that he has back in England. There are accusations of incest and sodomy in the air, and he has fled England forever into exile. And as you say, the vampirism, I mean, that's basically a sort of a metaphor, isn't it, for the sexual misconduct with which he's been charged who is Byron's publisher, is paying him a fortune to write a journal of what happens. It's Polidori who actually has written this account when it comes out in 1819. Polidori has a very awkward relationship with Byron because he, as well as being a doctor, he's an ambitious writer. He's actually written
危险关系式的爱情生活。空气中弥漫着乱伦和鸡奸的指控，他永远逃离了英国，开始了流亡生活。正如你所说，吸血鬼主义，我的意思是，这基本上是一种隐喻，不是吗？隐喻他被指控的性不端行为。谁是拜伦的出版商，正付给他一大笔钱让他写下所发生事情的日记。当这本书在1819年出版时，实际上是波利多里（Polidori）写下了这份记录。波利多里与拜伦的关系非常尴尬，因为他不仅是一名医生，还是一位雄心勃勃的作家。他实际上写了
three tragedies. Before they leave Dover for Ostend, he's actually written three tragedies. And before they leave Dover for Ostend, he reads one of these tragedies out to Byron and Hobhouse and both of them fall about laughing. Oh no. Yeah. It's very, very difficult. But Polidori knows the kind of details that his readership will want. So his description of Byron's arrival in Ghent after they've landed is very famous. As soon as he reached his room, Polidori wrote, Lord Byron fell like a thunderbolt upon the chambermaid. And did he? We don't know. And also, of course, what we don't know is whether the chambermaid is willing or not. Yeah, of course. There's all kinds of things being unspoken
三部悲剧。在他们离开多佛前往奥斯坦德之前，他实际上写了三部悲剧。在他们离开多佛前往奥斯坦德之前，他向拜伦和霍布豪斯（Hobhouse）朗读了其中一部悲剧，两人都笑得前仰后合。哦，不。是的。这非常、非常困难。但波利多里知道他的读者想要什么样的细节。所以他关于拜伦抵达根特后的描述非常出名。波利多里写道，拜伦勋爵一到房间，就像雷霆一样扑向了女仆。他真的做了吗？我们不知道。而且，当然，我们也不知道女仆是否自愿。是的，当然。有很多事情是未言明的
there. I mean, probably she was, I don't know. I mean, Byron is the most famous and handsome man in the world. But as they're going, Byron too is writing and he is returning to Childe Harold's pilgrimage. And so essentially as he travels through Europe and he's heading southwards, he never visits France, interestingly, but he goes down the Rhine towards Switzerland. In a very modest way that is typical of him, he is aligning all the agonies and the dramas of recent history with his own. So he visits the battlefield of Waterloo, he tours it, and there's this famous ball before the Battle of Waterloo held by the Duchess of Richmond. And Byron famously writes about it in Childe Harold, and he is essentially comparing the
在那里。我的意思是，也许她是，我不知道。我的意思是，拜伦是世界上最著名、最英俊的男人。但当他们出发时，拜伦也在写作，他正在回归《恰尔德·哈罗德游记》（Childe Harold's Pilgrimage）。所以本质上，当他穿越欧洲向南行进时，有趣的是他从未访问过法国，但他沿着莱茵河向瑞士走去。以一种他特有的谦逊方式，他将近期历史的所有痛苦和戏剧性与他自己的经历联系在一起。所以他参观了滑铁卢战场，游览了那里，滑铁卢战役前夕，里士满公爵夫人（Duchess of Richmond）举办了一场著名的舞会。拜伦在《恰尔德·哈罗德游记》中著名地写到了它，他本质上是在将
agonies of those at the ball to his own agonies. So he writes, there was a sound of revelry by night and Belgium's capital had gathered then. Her beauty and her chivalry and bright the lamps shone over fair women and brave men. A thousand hearts beat happily and when music arose with its voluptuous swell, soft eyes looked love to eyes which spake again and all went merry as a marriage bell. But hush, hark, a deep sound strikes like a rising knell. So this is the onset of war, of the Battle of Waterloo, but it's also the doom that will torpedo Byron's reputation as the social lion of London. And you may wonder, how can he get away with this? No matter how famous he is, how can someone conceivably compare his kind of marital agonies with all the dead of Waterloo. And I think it is precisely because with Napoleon now gone into exile, Byron is the most celebrated person in Europe. And he is an object of consuming curiosity wherever he goes. Tom, we talked before about, I mentioned Stendhal's novel, Le Rouge et le Noir,
舞会上人们的痛苦与他自己的痛苦进行比较。所以他写道，夜晚响起了狂欢的声音，比利时的首都聚集了那时。她的美丽和骑士精神，明亮的灯光照耀着美丽的女人和勇敢的男人。一千颗心快乐地跳动着，当音乐随着淫靡的浪潮响起，温柔的眼睛向眼睛投去爱意，诉说着再次，一切都像婚礼的钟声一样快乐。但嘘，听，一声深沉的声音像丧钟一样响起。所以这是战争的开始，滑铁卢战役的开始，但这也是将摧毁拜伦作为伦敦社交界宠儿声誉的厄运。你可能会问，他怎么能逃脱惩罚呢？无论他多么出名，一个人怎么能想象把他的婚姻痛苦与滑铁卢的所有死者相提并论。我认为正是因为拿破仑现在已经流亡，拜伦是欧洲最著名的人。无论他走到哪里，他都是人们极度好奇的对象。汤姆，我们之前谈过，我提到了司汤达（Stendhal）的小说《红与黑》（Le Rouge et le Noir），
Stendhal who met Byron, great French writer. And that novel captures this sort of adolescent hero worship of Napoleon by people who are seized with a kind of yearning to lift themselves out of provincial mediocrity. They worship Napoleon. Napoleon made himself a great man. He's above the common herd. Obviously, that impulse lies at the heart of romanticism, of the idea of the romantic artist. It's why people admire our old friend John Lennon. They think he's better than the norm. He's different. He's a suffering artist. He's special. Do you think the same people who idolize Napoleon idolize Byron? Completely. And I think more than that. I think that when they idolize Napoleon,
司汤达见过拜伦，伟大的法国作家。那部小说捕捉到了那些被一种渴望从平庸的省份生活中解脱出来的渴望所攫住的人们对拿破仑的青少年崇拜。他们崇拜拿破仑。拿破仑使自己成为一个伟人。他高于普通大众。显然，这种冲动是浪漫主义的核心，是浪漫主义艺术家理念的核心。这就是为什么人们钦佩我们的老朋友约翰·列侬（John Lennon）。他们认为他比普通人更好。他与众不同。他是一位受苦的艺术家。他是特别的。你认为那些崇拜拿破仑的人也崇拜拜伦吗？完全是。而且我认为不仅如此。我认为当他们崇拜拿破仑时，
Byron serves as a filter for them. So it does for Stendhal. I mean, Stendhal admires Napoleon, but he also admires Byron. And the two are conflated. And actually, particularly in France, interestingly. So Byron is hugely influenced on the course that French Romanticism takes. So it's not just an English thing. Okay, interesting. And that means that when he turns up in Switzerland, for instance, he is as obsessive a topic of interest to the Swiss as to
拜伦充当了他们的过滤器。所以对司汤达来说也是如此。我的意思是，司汤达钦佩拿破仑，但他也钦佩拜伦。两者被混为一谈。而且实际上，有趣的是，特别是在法国。所以拜伦对法国浪漫主义的发展方向产生了巨大的影响。所以这不仅仅是英国的事情。好的，有趣。这意味着当他出现在瑞士时，例如，他对于瑞士人来说，就像对于
English tourists there. Wherever he goes, people are watching him, pointing at him. Byron reports that he walks into a room and a woman faints. He says, that's a bit much. Entrepreneurial Swiss hoteliers are hiring out binoculars that they can spy on him. So it's awful. And it's not surprising that when Byron, he arrives at the Hotel D'Angleterre in Geneva, he's asked to give his name and his age, and he writes down, I am 100. He's feeling exhausted by everything. And so it's not surprising, therefore, that he is in a mood to welcome interesting and convivial company.
那里的英国游客一样，是一个令人着迷的话题。无论他走到哪里，人们都在注视着他，指着他。拜伦报告说，他走进一个房间，一个女人晕倒了。他说，这有点过分了。有进取心的瑞士酒店经营者正在出租望远镜，以便他们可以窥探他。所以这太糟糕了。难怪当拜伦抵达日内瓦的英国酒店（Hotel D'Angleterre）时，他被要求提供姓名和年龄，他写下：我100岁了。他感到被一切弄得精疲力竭。因此，难怪他心情愉快，欢迎有趣和欢乐的陪伴。
Yeah. The company of people who will not cause him grief. And on the 27th of May, 1816, he and Polidori have been out on a boat on Lake Geneva. And they come back and they get onto the jetty. And there on the jetty, a young man and two women are waiting for him. And this is one of the famous meetings in literary history. Because of course, that young man is the 23-year-old Percy Bysshe Shelley, who like Byron is a poet. He's not published and famous in the way that Byron is, but he kind of pushes sceptical trends that Byron has to very radical limits. So he's an opium atheist, an open Republican,
是的。那些不会给他带来悲伤的人的陪伴。1816年5月27日，他和波利多里在日内瓦湖上划船。他们回来后上了码头。码头上，一个年轻人和两个女人在等他。这是文学史上著名的会面之一。因为当然，那个年轻人是23岁的珀西·比希·雪莱（Percy Bysshe Shelley），像拜伦一样，他也是一位诗人。他不像拜伦那样出版作品并成名，但他将拜伦所持有的怀疑倾向推向了非常激进的极限。所以他是一个鸦片无神论者，一个公开的共和主义者，
an enthusiast for free love. And he has with him two stepsisters. So one of them, Mary Godwin, who in due course will become Mary Shelley, is the daughter of two very famous parents. So William Godwin is a kind of radical, sceptical philosopher. And her mother, Mary Wollstonecraft, is pioneering feminist. And she is sleeping with Shelley. And with her is her stepsister, who's younger than her, Claire Claremont. And the meeting between Shelley and the two stepsisters with Byron is initially awkward. This is partly because Polidori actually is very saturnine, very good looking, and Shelley mistakes Polidori actually is very saturnine, very good looking, and Shelley mistakes Polidori for Byron. Oh my word. So that slightly deflates Byron's image.
一个自由恋爱的狂热者。他带着两个继姐妹。所以其中一个，玛丽·戈德温（Mary Godwin），也就是后来的玛丽·雪莱（Mary Shelley），是两位非常著名父母的女儿。所以威廉·戈德温（William Godwin）是一位激进的、怀疑论的哲学家。她的母亲玛丽·沃斯通克拉夫特（Mary Wollstonecraft）是先驱女权主义者。她正与雪莱同居。和她在一起的是她的继姐妹，比她年轻的克莱尔·克莱蒙特（Claire Claremont）。雪莱和两个继姐妹与拜伦的会面最初很尴尬。这部分是因为波利多里实际上非常阴郁、非常英俊，而雪莱误把波利多里当成了拜伦。哦，天哪。所以这稍微削弱了拜伦的形象。
It does, slightly. He can be mistaken for him. It's also the fact both men are naturally shy, so it takes some time for their reserve to break down. And it's also because there is a massive fly in the ointment, and that is that Claire Claremont has not only slept with Byron, but got pregnant by him. And so she had set out to seduce him while he was in the depths of misery. His wife had left him. He's being abused across London. And so he basically succumbs to her advances. He'd been upfront right from the beginning. I'm not interested in a relationship. I'll do this because you're kind of pestering me. But I don't want anything more to do with you. So his comment on it was, I never loved nor pretended to love her, but a man is a man. And if a girl of 18, in fact,
确实，稍微削弱了一点。他可能会被误认为是拜伦。这也是因为两个男人天生害羞，所以他们的矜持需要一些时间才能打破。而且还有一个巨大的障碍，那就是克莱尔·克莱蒙特不仅与拜伦睡过，还怀了他的孩子。所以当他处于痛苦深渊时，她就出发去诱惑他。他的妻子离开了他。他在伦敦受到虐待。所以他基本上屈服于她的追求。他从一开始就很坦率。我对一段关系不感兴趣。我会这样做是因为你在纠缠我。但我不想再和你有什么瓜葛了。所以他对此的评论是，我从未爱过她，也没有假装爱过她，但男人就是男人。如果一个18岁的女孩，事实上，
she's 17, comes prancing to you at all hours, there is but one way. And so Claire, a bit like Caroline Lamb, is obsessed with him, is pursuing him. But to be fair, she's pregnant by him. I mean, it's understandable that she would be. Yeah, she is. And she's persuaded Shelley and Mary, basically, to go to Geneva so that they can meet with Byron. So despite the awkwardness of this beginning, Byron and Shelley get on well. And as I'm sure most listeners will know, because this is very, very celebrated, the two poets, the two stepsisters, Polidori, they essentially spend that summer
她才17岁，在任何时候都向你扑来，只有一种办法。所以克莱尔，有点像卡罗琳·兰姆，对他着迷，在追求他。但公平地说，她怀了他的孩子。我的意思是，她会这样是可以理解的。是的，她是。她基本上说服了雪莱和玛丽去日内瓦，这样他们就可以见到拜伦。所以尽管开始时很尴尬，但拜伦和雪莱相处得很好。而且我相信大多数听众都会知道，因为这非常、非常著名，两位诗人、两位继姐妹、波利多里，他们基本上度过了那个夏天
together. So the Shelleys hire a small house beside Lake Geneva and Byron rents a villa, the Villa Diodati, where John Milton, the great poet, had once stayed, which is above Shelley's villa, kind of spectacular views over the lake towards the Dura Mountains. And they go on tours around the neighbouring sites, but they are kept in by what is famously terrible weather. Yeah. It's the year without a summer. Is that right?
在一起。所以雪莱夫妇在日内瓦湖边租了一栋小房子，拜伦租了一栋别墅，迪奥达蒂别墅（Villa Diodati），伟大的诗人约翰·弥尔顿（John Milton）曾经住过那里，它在雪莱别墅的上方，可以欣赏到湖泊向汝拉山脉（Dura Mountains）的壮丽景色。他们去参观了附近的景点，但由于众所周知的糟糕天气，他们被困在里面。是的。那是没有夏天的一年。是这样吗？
Yeah. So there's been this volcano that has erupted in Indonesia the year before and the ash has basically blotted out the sun. And Dominic, it's this, you've done a series, haven't you, on Frankenstein and science fiction? Yeah, TV series. Yeah. Years ago, years ago. So they have the famous competition, don't they?
是的。所以前一年印度尼西亚发生了一次火山爆发，火山灰基本上遮住了太阳。多米尼克，你做过一个系列节目，不是吗？关于《弗兰肯斯坦》（Frankenstein）和科幻小说？是的，电视系列节目。是的。几年前，几年前。所以他们进行了著名的比赛，不是吗？
Write a ghost story. It's actually a Doctor Who story about this, Tom, where they've got a Cyberman in the cellar, but we don't need to get into that now. Don't go into that. They're all sort of trying to scare each other with different stories, aren't they? Yeah, so Polidori gives an account of it
写一个鬼故事。汤姆，这实际上是一个关于这个的《神秘博士》（Doctor Who）故事，他们在地下室里有一个赛博人（Cyberman），但我们现在不需要讨论那个。不要讨论那个。他们都在试图用不同的故事吓唬对方，不是吗？是的，所以波利多里对此做了一个记录
and 12 o'clock really began to talk ghostly. LB, so that's Byron, repeated some verses of Coleridge's Christabel of The Witch's Breast. When silence ensued, Shelley suddenly shrieking and putting his hands to his head ran out of the room with a candle.
12点钟真的开始谈论鬼魂了。LB，也就是拜伦，重复了柯勒律治（Coleridge）的《克里斯塔贝尔》（Christabel）中关于女巫乳房的一些诗句。当沉默降临时，雪莱突然尖叫起来，双手抱头，拿着蜡烛跑出了房间。
He was looking at Mrs. Shelley and suddenly thought of a woman he had heard of who had eyes instead of nipples, which, taking hold of his mind, horrified him. To be fair, that would freak you out. I mean, that is... Yeah, it would, wouldn't it? It absolutely would.
他当时正看着雪莱夫人，突然想到了一个他听说过的女人，她的乳头位置长着眼睛，这占据了他的思想，让他感到恐惧。公平地说，那会把你吓坏的。我的意思是，那是……是的，会，不是吗？绝对会。
Especially, I mean, if I was Mrs. Shelley, I would be quite offended by that. Well, there's the Ken Russell film, Gothic. Right, I've never seen that. Which brings all that to life. So this ghost story competition, Shelley gets bored, Polidori's story is terrible, but there are two hugely influential stories
特别是，我的意思是，如果我是雪莱夫人，我会对此感到相当被冒犯。嗯，有肯·罗素（Ken Russell）的电影《哥特》（Gothic）。对，我没看过。它把这一切都带入了生活。所以这个鬼故事比赛，雪莱感到无聊，波利多里的故事很糟糕，但有两个影响巨大的故事
that do emerge from it. And the most famous of these, of course, is Frankenstein. And we will be doing an episode specifically on Frankenstein. We will. We'll do a separate episode on Frankenstein because it's such a brilliant story. Yeah. So we'll just park that. But Byron tells a story which is clearly very autobiographical about an aristocrat who comes from the Balkans to London and turns out to be a vampire. And as I said, he's drawing on superstitions that he had heard in Greece and Albania. And he wrote a poem called The Jawa, in which a curse is delivered on
确实从中产生了。当然，其中最著名的是《弗兰肯斯坦》。我们将专门制作一集关于《弗兰肯斯坦》的节目。我们会。我们会做一集关于《弗兰肯斯坦》的独立节目，因为它是一个如此精彩的故事。是的。所以我们先搁置一下。但拜伦讲了一个故事，显然非常具有自传色彩，关于一位从巴尔干半岛来到伦敦的贵族，结果发现是一个吸血鬼。正如我所说，他借鉴了他在希腊和阿尔巴尼亚听到的迷信。他写了一首名为《异教徒》（The Jawa）的诗，其中对
the eponymous Jawa. The Jawa is a Turkish word for a kind of a Frank, a Westerner. And this is the curse. Thy course shall from its tomb be rent, then ghastly haunt thy native place and suck the blood of all thy race there from thy daughter sister wife at midnight drain the stream of life yet loathe the banquet which before must feed thy livid living course thy victims ere they yet expire shall know the demon for their sire as cursing thee thou cursing them thy flowers are withered on the stem and what is interesting about that we talked in the previous episode about Lady Byron going to her doctor and saying that Byron has this idea that he is cursed to destroy all those
同名的异教徒发出了诅咒。“异教徒”是一个土耳其词，指一种法兰克人，即西方人。这就是诅咒：你的尸体将从坟墓中被撕裂，然后可怕地困扰你的故乡，吸干你所有族人的血，从你的女儿、姐妹、妻子那里，在午夜抽干生命的源泉，然而厌恶那必须喂养你苍白、活着的尸体的宴席，你的受害者在他们断气之前，将认出这个恶魔是他们的祖先，当你诅咒他们，他们诅咒你时，你的花朵在茎上枯萎。而有趣的是，我们在上一集中谈到拜伦夫人去找她的医生，说拜伦有一种想法，认为他被诅咒去摧毁所有那些
who love him and who he loves. I mean, there's elements of that. Totally. Their daughter, sister, wife. I mean, that sounds like the inhabitants of Byron's bed. I mean, but the idea of sexuality and sexual desire being poisonous in some way and being tainted, you can see why that comes from him. It's barely even his subconscious. It's his consciousness. image of the aristocratic vampire who is beautiful as well as deadly becomes so influential. I mean, you wouldn't have Count Dracula without Lord Ruthven, who is based on Lord Byron. You make the point, don't you, that previously vampires had been peasant figures climbing out of graves in fly-bitten Vulcan villages. Dirty, yeah. Yeah. The idea of the suave. Count Dracula is so Byronic. I mean, think of Francis Ford Coppola's film.
爱他和他所爱的人。我的意思是，有这方面的因素。完全是。他们的女儿、姐妹、妻子。我的意思是，这听起来像是拜伦床上的居民。我的意思是，但性欲和性渴望以某种方式是有毒的、被玷污的想法，你可以看出为什么这来自他。这甚至几乎不是他的潜意识。这是他的意识。贵族吸血鬼的形象，既美丽又致命，变得如此有影响力。我的意思是，没有鲁芬勋爵，你就不会有德古拉伯爵（Count Dracula），而鲁芬勋爵是以拜伦勋爵为原型的。你提出了一个观点，不是吗？即在此之前，吸血鬼是农民形象，从苍蝇叮咬的巴尔干村庄的坟墓中爬出来。肮脏的，是的。是的。那种温文尔雅的想法。德古拉伯爵是如此拜伦式。我的意思是，想想弗朗西斯·福特·科波拉（Francis Ford Coppola）的电影。
Anyway. So all of this, the hanging out with the Shelleys, I mean, none of this does anything to improve Byron's reputation. Because Shelley is notorious. People think that he's sleeping with both the sisters, the stepsisters, but they're talked of as being sisters. And so back in London, the rumours will be that Byron and Shelley are engaged in a league of incest. And so that's making play with Byron's own reputation. Byron, when he hears about this, is furious because actually it's not true. Shelley isn't sleeping with Claire as well as with Mary. And also I think what is more is that Byron's been behaving quite badly in these episodes. He is less radical than Shelley in his attitudes, for instance, towards free love.
无论如何。所以这一切，与雪莱夫妇在一起，我的意思是，这一切都没有改善拜伦的声誉。因为雪莱臭名昭著。人们认为他与两个姐妹，继姐妹睡在一起，但她们被称为姐妹。所以回到伦敦，谣言将是拜伦和雪莱参与了一个乱伦联盟。所以这在利用拜伦自己的声誉。拜伦听到这个消息时，非常愤怒，因为这实际上不是真的。雪莱并没有像与玛丽那样也与克莱尔睡在一起。而且我认为更重要的是，拜伦在这些事件中表现得相当糟糕。例如，在对待自由恋爱方面，他不如雪莱激进。
I mean, that may come as a surprise to listeners to the previous episode, but Shelley really is kind of radical in his views. And Shelley also is capable of finding Byron shocking, and not only shocking, but also he's quite intimidated by him, I think, both because he's a lord, but also because of his fame. And of course, a further shadow is cast by the fact that Byron is still refusing to have anything to do with Clare. And so the Shelleys leave Geneva on the 29th of August after their three-month stay with Byron, and they discuss the future of Clare's child when she, in due course, gives birth to it. Byron proposes that Augusta should raise it. The Shelleys say, absolutely not. Well, his sister that he's been sleeping with. I mean, come on, that's ridiculous.
我的意思是，这可能会让上一集的听众感到惊讶，但雪莱在观点上确实相当激进。而且雪莱也有能力发现拜伦令人震惊，不仅令人震惊，而且我认为他也被他吓到了，既因为他是一位勋爵，也因为他的名声。当然，另一个阴影是拜伦仍然拒绝与克莱尔有任何瓜葛。所以雪莱夫妇在与拜伦共度三个月后，于8月29日离开日内瓦，他们讨论了克莱尔的孩子在未来出生后的去向。拜伦提议奥古斯塔（Augusta）应该抚养它。雪莱夫妇说，绝对不行。嗯，他一直与之同居的妹妹。我的意思是，拜仁，那太荒谬了。
It's finally agreed that the child, when he or she is born, will live with either one of the parents. And Byron reluctantly agrees with this. Clare goes, Byron does not say goodbye to her, does not embrace her. He doesn't want to have anything to do with her. So the Shelleys go back to England and mid-January 1817, Cl's crossed the Alps from Switzerland, he's travelled through Northern Italy, and he has ended up in Venice. And Allegra is a Venetian name. And by the time that Percy and Mary Shelley, accompanied by Clare and Allegra, set out for Italy to hand over Allegra to Byron, which is what has been agreed, by this point, Byron has been settled in Venice on and off for over a year. And it's basically, it's his kind of place rather in the
最终商定，孩子出生后，将与父母中的一方生活。拜伦勉强同意了这一点。克莱尔走了，拜伦没有和她告别，没有拥抱她。他不想和她有任何瓜葛。所以雪莱夫妇回到英国，1817年1月中旬，克莱尔越过阿尔卑斯山从瑞士来到这里，他穿越了意大利北部，最终到达了威尼斯。而阿莱格拉（Allegra）是一个威尼斯名字。当珀西和玛丽·雪莱在克莱尔和阿莱格拉的陪同下出发前往意大利，将阿莱格拉交给拜伦（这是商定好的）时，此时，拜伦已经在威尼斯断断续续地定居了一年多。这基本上是他的地方，就像
way that Greece was his kind of place, because it has a similar kind of romance. So he writes about this in Childe Harold, which he's continuing. I loved her from my boyhood. She to me was as a fairy city of the heart, rising like water columns from the sea of joy, the suchan and of wealth, the mart. But just as Greece is under Turkish rule, Venice in the wake of the heart, rising like water columns from the sea, of joy the sojourn and of wealth the mart. But just as Greece is under Turkish rule, Venice, in the wake of the Napoleonic Wars, is under Austrian rule. So Venice had been a free republic, a great power, but her independence had been snuffed out by Napoleon. And with Napoleon's overthrow, Venice has become part of the Austrian empire. So that's all very tragic, but it's not just the kind of the faded tragedy of it all. It's also the fact that Venice, despite its shabby gentility, is full of life and it's a place that is devoted to pleasure.
希腊是他的地方一样，因为它有一种类似的浪漫色彩。所以他在《恰尔德·哈罗德游记》中写到了这一点，他正在继续写这部作品。“我从少年时代就爱她。她对我来说就像心灵的童话城市，像水柱一样从欢乐的海洋中升起，那是财富的居所和市场。”但就像希腊处于土耳其统治下一样，威尼斯在拿破仑战争之后，处于奥地利统治下。所以威尼斯曾经是一个自由共和国，一个大国，但她的独立被拿破仑扼杀了。随着拿破仑的倒台，威尼斯已成为奥地利帝国的一部分。所以这一切都很悲惨，但这不仅仅是那种褪色的悲剧。这也是因为威尼斯，尽管它破败不堪，却充满了活力，是一个致力于享乐的地方。
And Byron writing home to all his friends lets everybody know. So his letters, as I said, are wonderful. This is a kind of payoff. It's typical. Good night, he writes, or rather morning. It is four and the dawn gleams over the Grand Canal and unshadows the Rialto. I must to bed. So that's very much the kind of, you know, you'd show off.
拜伦写信给所有的朋友，让每个人都知道。所以他的信，正如我所说，非常精彩。这是一种回报。这是典型的。“晚安，”他写道，“或者说是早晨。现在是四点，黎明在运河上闪烁，照亮了里亚托桥（Rialto）。我必须去睡觉了。”所以这非常像那种，你知道，炫耀。
Basically, when your friend goes abroad, you don't want to hear that kind of thing. You want to hear they're having a terrible time and being bitten by mosquitoes and mugged. You don't want to hear this business. Right. But I think that, again, Byron is a trailblazer in a way that we might take for granted because he basically is the first British expat to make living abroad seem glamorous in a way that becomes accessible to lots and lots of people. Because when he writes all this kind of stuff, first of all in Childe Harold, but then in much lighter,
基本上，当你的朋友出国时，你不想听到那种事情。你想听到他们过得很糟糕，被蚊子叮咬，被抢劫。你不想听到这种事情。对。但我认为，拜伦再次成为先驱，以一种我们可能认为理所当然的方式，因为他基本上是第一个让在国外生活看起来如此迷人的英国侨民，以至于许多人都能接触到。因为当他写下所有这些东西时，首先是在《恰尔德·哈罗德游记》中，然后是在更轻快、
funnier poems that kind of bring alive the sense of how brilliant it is to be out in Venice on a gondola and living in a palazzo on the Grand Canal as Byron is doing. Everyone just kind of sucks it up. They love it. So Turner and Ruskin will follow in Byron's footsteps to Venice. But so also, of course, does James Bond. I mean, that idea of Venice as a place of glamour, where if you are an Englishman in Venice, you're living the dream. It is Byron who establishes that as an aspiration that people back in England can dream of having. James Bond, of course, is there with Dr. Holly Goodhead, Tom, in Moonraker. And his gondola comes out of the canals and travels over land through St. Mark's Square while he's being chased by men with machine guns. Okay, so there aren't machine guns.
更有趣的诗歌中，这些诗歌生动地展现了在威尼斯乘坐贡多拉，住在运河上的宫殿里是多么美妙，就像拜伦正在做的那样。每个人都只是吸收了它。他们喜欢它。所以特纳（Turner）和罗斯金（Ruskin）将追随拜伦的脚步来到威尼斯。当然，詹姆斯·邦德（James Bond）也是如此。我的意思是，威尼斯作为一个迷人地方的想法，如果你是一个在威尼斯的英国人，你就在实现梦想。正是拜伦将其确立为英国人可以梦想实现的愿望。詹姆斯·邦德，当然，和霍莉·古德黑德（Holly Goodhead）博士在那里，汤姆，在《太空城》（Moonraker）中。他的贡多拉从运河中出来，在陆地上穿过圣马可广场，同时被拿着机关枪的人追赶。好吧，所以没有机关枪。
No. But for Byron, there is all kinds of stuff going on. Yeah. So he writes about this in a poem called Beppo, which is the first in his kind of comic style. The moment night with dusky mantle covers the skies and the more duskily the better. The time less liked by husbands than by lovers begins and prudery flings aside her fetter and gaiety on restless tiptoe hovers giggling with all the gallants who beset her and there are songs and quavers roaring humming guitars and every other
没有。但对于拜伦来说，各种各样的事情都在发生。是的。所以他在一首名为《贝波》（Beppo）的诗中写到了这一点，这是他那种喜剧风格的第一部。“当夜晚用昏暗的斗篷覆盖天空时，越昏暗越好。丈夫们比情人更不喜欢的时间开始了，矜持抛开了她的束缚，欢乐在不安的脚尖上盘旋，咯咯笑着，与所有纠缠她的情人们在一起，有歌声和颤音，咆哮着，哼唱着，吉他和其他
sort of strumming every sort of strumming very nice so that's very roger moore the every sort of strumming it's very fancy having a little very Roger Moore, the every sort of strumming. It is very Roger Moore. Do you fancy having a little strum with me? You know, that kind of thing. However, perhaps the Roger Moore parallel is more apposite than I realised, because am I not right in saying that at this point, Byron is a little too old and is perhaps not quite as honed as he might have been in his Daniel Craig pomp?
各种各样的弹奏，各种各样的弹奏，非常好，所以这非常罗杰·摩尔（Roger Moore），那种各种各样的弹奏，非常时髦，有一个小小的非常罗杰·摩尔，那种各种各样的弹奏。这非常罗杰·摩尔。你想和我一起弹奏一下吗？你知道，那种事情。然而，也许罗杰·摩尔的平行比我意识到的更贴切，因为我没说错吧，此时的拜伦有点太老了，也许不像他在丹尼尔·克雷格（Daniel Craig）鼎盛时期那样精干？
I mean, he's only 30 by this point. Okay. But we have a report by John Hanson who goes out to meet Byron, his lawyer, to sort out his financial affairs. And he takes his son with him. And this son reports that although Byron's only 30, he looked 40. His face had become pale, bloated and sallow. He had grown very fat, his shoulders broad and round, and the knuckles of his hands were lost in fat. Tom, you know as well as I do that I cannot abide a fat man. That is very disappointing.
我的意思是，他此时才30岁。好的。但我们有一份约翰·汉森（John Hanson）的报告，他去见拜伦，他的律师，来处理他的财务事务。他带着他的儿子一起去。这个儿子报告说，虽然拜伦才30岁，但他看起来像40岁。他的脸变得苍白、浮肿、蜡黄。他长得很胖，肩膀宽阔而圆润，手上的指关节淹没在脂肪里。汤姆，你和我一样清楚，我无法忍受一个胖子。这非常令人失望。
Yeah, you love your dieting, as of course Byron had done in his days of pomp, but he's clearly letting himself go. And this is also what Shelley feels when he arrives. So they've come to Italy. He's sent Allegra with her Swiss nursemaid to Byron, and Byron's palazzo is full of all kinds of animals and pets. And Allegra basically just becomes another pet in the palazzo. And Byron's very fond of her, but I don't think he's a particularly attentive father. Anyway, Shelley turns up a few months later with Claire. Byron refuses to see Claire, but he does meet up with Shelley.
是的，你喜欢你的节食，正如拜伦在鼎盛时期所做的那样，但他显然在放纵自己。这也是雪莱到达时所感受到的。所以他们来到意大利。他把阿莱格拉和她的瑞士保姆送到了拜伦那里，拜伦的宫殿里到处都是各种各样的动物和宠物。阿莱格拉基本上成了宫殿里的另一只宠物。拜伦非常喜欢她，但我认为他不是一个特别细心的父亲。无论如何，雪莱几个月后带着克莱尔出现了。拜伦拒绝见克莱尔，但他确实见了雪莱。
And Byron's delighted to see Shelley. Shelley is less delighted to see Byron because despite all his enthusiasm for free love, he has quite a prim side and actually quite a xenophobic side as well, weirdly, because since he will end up living in Italy, he complains that all of Byron's mistresses stink of garlic. That's very good. I like that. And he also hints that Byron is getting back to his old ways. So Byron himself refers to Venice as the sea Sodom. And Shelley talks darkly of, and I'm quoting Shelley here, wretches who seem almost to have lost the gait and physiognomy of man and do not scruple to
拜伦很高兴见到雪莱。雪莱见到拜伦则没那么高兴，因为尽管他对自由恋爱充满热情，但他有相当古板的一面，而且奇怪的是，也有相当排外的一面，因为既然他最终会住在意大利，他抱怨拜伦所有的情妇都有一股大蒜味。这非常好。我喜欢那个。他还暗示拜伦正在回到他的老路上去。所以拜伦本人称威尼斯为“海上所多玛”（Sea Sodom）。雪莱阴郁地谈论着，我引用雪莱的话，“那些似乎几乎失去了人的步态和面相的恶棍，毫不犹豫地
avow practices which are not only not named, but I believe seldom even conceived in England. So Shelley there making an unexpected pitch to write for a tabloid newspaper in the 1980s. Very much. So Shelley's still full of admiration for Byron, but feels that he's wasting his life. But he's not wrong, right? I mean, I was stunned when you said he's only 30. Of course, he's packed so much in, hasn't he? But he has become very dissipated. I mean, there's a definite Elvis side to him, isn't there, at this point?
承认那些不仅没有被命名，而且我相信在英国甚至很少被构想出来的做法。”所以雪莱在那里做了一个意想不到的尝试，为1980年代的小报写稿。非常多。所以雪莱仍然对拜伦充满钦佩，但觉得他在浪费生命。但他没说错，对吧？我的意思是，你说他才30岁时我惊呆了。当然，他经历了很多，不是吗？但他变得非常放纵。我的意思是，他身上有一种明确的猫王（Elvis）特质，不是吗，在这一点上？
Yes. And it's interesting you mention that because you remember Camille Paglia, who wrote Sexual Personae, a very kind of trendy analysis of culture from Nefertiti up to the present day. On her chapter on Byron, she does a brilliant comparison of Byron to Elvis. Okay. The same kind of look, the same fight against overweight and everything. I mean, the one thing to say is that Byron's poetry is really becoming incredibly sophisticated, brilliant at this point. But Shelley feels that Byron could be much more than that,
是的。你提到这一点很有趣，因为你记得卡米尔·帕格利亚（Camille Paglia），她写了《性人格》（Sexual Personae），一种从奈费尔提蒂（Nefertiti）到现在非常时髦的文化分析。在她关于拜伦的章节中，她对拜伦和猫王进行了精彩的比较。好的。同样的外表，同样的对抗超重等等。我的意思是，要说的一件事是，拜伦的诗歌在这一点上变得非常复杂、精彩。但雪莱觉得拜伦可以不仅仅是那样，
that Byron's own dreams of becoming a kind of Napoleonic figure. Shelley feels that there is truth to this. And he writes a poem called Julian and Madelow, in which he's basically ventriloquizing the conversations that he and Byron have had. So Byron appears in this as Count Madelow. And Shelley writes a preface to the poem, and in it, he's giving basically a description of Byron. And he writes, he, Madelow Byron, is a person of the most consummate genius and capable, if he would direct his energies to such an end, of becoming the redeemer of his degraded country, so Venice or Britain. But it is his weakness to be proud. He derives from a comparison of his own extraordinary mind with the dwarfish intellects that surround him,
拜伦自己成为拿破仑式人物的梦想。雪莱觉得这是有道理的。他写了一首名为《朱利安和马德洛》（Julian and Madelow）的诗，在诗中他基本上是在为他和拜伦进行的对话配音。所以拜伦在其中以马德洛伯爵（Count Madelow）的身份出现。雪莱为这首诗写了一篇序言，在序言中，他基本上是在描述拜伦。他写道，他，马德洛·拜伦，是一个拥有最完美天才的人，如果他能将自己的精力引导到这样一个目标上，就有能力成为他堕落国家的救赎者，即威尼斯或英国。但他骄傲是他的弱点。他从将自己非凡的思想与周围矮小的智力进行比较中，
an intense apprehension of the nothingness of human life. So it's that kind of existentialist quality of Byronic despair that Shelley is reacting against, because Shelley's much more utopian. He believes that humanity can enter a golden age. Byron's much more pessimistic. And I think Byron's response to this would be to say, well, it's too late. I am a notorious exile. What prospect do I have of ever redeeming a degraded country? It seems a complete fantasy. And yet, Tom, in the second half, the final part of this great epic, one of the most colourful stories I have to say we've ever done on The Rest Is History, one of the countries that he had always loved is going to return in his imagination, isn't it? And
产生了一种对人类生活虚无的强烈恐惧。所以这就是雪莱所反对的那种拜伦式绝望的唯心主义特质，因为雪莱更乌托邦。他相信人类可以进入一个黄金时代。拜伦更悲观。我认为拜伦对此的回应是，好吧，太晚了。我是一个臭名昭著的流亡者。我有什么希望去救赎一个堕落的国家？这看起来完全是幻想。然而，汤姆，在下半部分，这部伟大史诗的最后一部分，我必须说这是我们在《历史的余味》中做过的最丰富多彩的故事之一，他一直热爱的国家之一将在他的想象中回归，不是吗？而且
that country is, of course, Greece. So Byron will be going back to Greece and his appointment with destiny after the break. and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. Welcome back to The Rest Is History, the very last leg of our great epic journey through the life and times of Lord Byron. Tom, with the end of 1819, there is a sense now, perhaps for the first time, that Byron is beginning to, dare I say, grow a bit and calm down. He has moved from the city he called Sea Sodom, Venice, to Ravenna, which is even more decayed and dilapidated and faded.
那个国家当然是希腊。所以拜伦将回到希腊，并在休息后赴约命运。以及抢先观看现场门票，前往 therestisentertainment.com。那是 therestisentertainment.com。欢迎回到《历史的余味》，我们通过拜伦勋爵的生活和时代进行的伟大史诗之旅的最后一站。汤姆，随着1819年的结束，现在有一种感觉，也许是第一次，拜伦开始，我敢说，成长并冷静下来。他已经从他称之为“海上所多玛”的威尼斯搬到了拉文纳（Ravenna），那里更加衰败、破旧和褪色。
And actually, I mean, Ravenna's very nice mosaics, but it's kind of provincial. And that's the one thing Byron has always hated. Yeah, it's odd. And people who come to visit Byron and Ravenna say, why have you come here? It's not your kind of place at all. And the reason is that he has fallen for a woman who will be his last and most enduring love. And she's a 19-year-old Italian contessa, Teresa Guccioli. And she and her husband, and inevitably there is a husband, have their palazzo in Ravenna. So Benita Eisler in her biography of Byron describes Teresa as a romantic realist, shrewd more than intelligent, innocent and amoral, affected and feeling, worldly and provincial.
实际上，我的意思是，拉文纳有非常漂亮的马赛克，但它有点偏远。而这是拜伦一直讨厌的一点。是的，这很奇怪。那些来拉文纳拜访拜伦的人说，你为什么要来这里？这根本不是你的地方。原因是他爱上了一个女人，她将是他最后也是最持久的爱人。她是一位19岁的意大利伯爵夫人，特蕾莎·圭乔利（Teresa Guccioli）。她和她的丈夫，不可避免地有一个丈夫，在拉文纳有他们的宫殿。所以贝尼塔·艾斯勒（Benita Eisler）在她的拜伦传记中将特蕾莎描述为一位浪漫的现实主义者，精明多于聪明，天真而无道德，做作而有感情，世俗而偏远。
I mean, those are a lot of just opposed categories. It's hard to know what that means. Well, Benita Rice also says that she's simultaneously highly intelligent and utterly frivolous. Exactly. Once blonde and brunette, tall and short. No, I don't think so. I mean, I think you can see that they're being very smart, but also being frivolous. There is something there that would appeal to Byron, I think.
我的意思是，这些是很多并列的类别。很难知道这意味着什么。嗯，贝尼塔·赖斯（Benita Rice）也说她既非常聪明又完全轻浮。完全正确。既是金发又是黑发，又高又矮。不，我不这么认为。我的意思是，我认为你可以看出他们既非常聪明，又非常轻浮。那里有一些东西会吸引拜伦，我想。
Yeah, I can see that. But also what she gives to Byron is also what Augusta had given Byron, which is a kind of complete and unwavering devotion. And it's important to say that by this point, Augusta is no longer communicating with Byron in the kind of intimate and personal ways that she had previously done, because Lady Byron is still very much on the scene and has set it as one of her missions to try and redeem Augusta from her sinful state. So Lady Byron has been born again. She's become part of the evangelical sect that surrounds William Wilberforce, the great anti-slavery campaigner. Lady Byron is a committed anti-slavery campaigner. She is committed to
是的，我能看出这一点。但她给拜伦的也是奥古斯塔曾经给拜伦的，这是一种完全且坚定不移的奉献。重要的是要说，到这一点时，奥古斯塔不再以她以前那种亲密和个人的方式与拜伦交流，因为拜伦夫人仍然非常活跃，并将试图从罪恶状态中救赎奥古斯塔作为她的使命之一。所以拜伦夫人已经重生了。她成为了围绕威廉·威尔伯福斯（William Wilberforce）的福音派教派的一部分，他是伟大的反奴隶制运动者。拜伦夫人是一位坚定的反奴隶制运动者。她致力于
improving the education of the poor, all these kinds of things. But among her moral missions is the urge to redeem Augusta. And so as a result of that, Byron is always bewildered by these very stiff letters that he's starting to get from his sister, in which basically she doesn't tell him anything. And so I think for that reason, he's very susceptible to an Augusta-like figure, which is clearly what Teresa is. And he stays with her for the rest of his life. And it's as close to a monogamous relationship as he will ever know. But it is, of course, a very Byronic form of monogamy in all kinds of ways. So Teresa signals her willingness to have him as a lover by Caroline Lamb style, sending Byron a clipping of
改善穷人的教育，所有这些事情。但她的道德使命之一是救赎奥古斯塔的冲动。因此，拜伦总是对这些他开始从他妹妹那里收到的非常生硬的信件感到困惑，在信中她基本上什么都没告诉他。所以我认为出于这个原因，他非常容易受到像奥古斯塔那样的人物的影响，这显然就是特蕾莎。他余生都和她在一起。这和他所知道的单配偶关系一样接近。但当然，这是一种非常拜伦式的单配偶形式，在各种方面。所以特蕾莎通过卡罗琳·兰姆的方式，向拜伦发送了一份剪报，示意她愿意让他成为情人。
her pubic hair. So my question here is, is this a common practice in the early 19th century or is she deliberately copying Caroline Lamb? Has she heard about it? Probably the latter, I think. Yeah. Because people aren't doing this in Jane Austen, right? Oh, I'm just going to send Mr. Wickham, you know, whatever. I don't think so.
她的阴毛。所以我的问题是，这在19世纪早期是一种常见的做法，还是她在刻意模仿卡罗琳·兰姆？她听说过这件事吗？我想大概是后者。是的。因为在简·奥斯汀的小说里人们不会这样做，对吧？哦，我只是要打发威克姆先生，你知道，随便吧。我不这么认为。
So there's that. There's also the freestorm of danger because her husband, who is 70. Okay. So, you know, Teresa is late teens. Husband is 70. He's done well for himself. He's a very powerful figure. He's a kind of diplomat who's managed to get on well both with Napoleon and the Pope,
所以情况就是这样。还有一种危险的氛围，因为她的丈夫已经70岁了。好吧。所以，你知道，特蕾莎才十几岁。丈夫70岁。他事业有成。他是一个非常有权势的人物。他是一位外交官，既能与拿破仑相处融洽，也能与教皇搞好关系，
which is impressive. Right. He's believed with some credibility to have murdered people who got in his way, including a previous wife. Okay. She has not done well for herself. But he's very rich. And although she comes from an aristocratic family, Count Guccioli, he's a significant figure in Italian politics. So she has done very well for herself. And basically
这令人印象深刻。没错。人们有理由相信他曾谋杀过阻碍他的人，包括前任妻子。好吧。她自己的生活并不如意。但他非常有钱。虽然她出身贵族家庭，但古乔利伯爵是意大利政坛的重要人物。所以她自己的生活其实过得很好。基本上
she wants to have her cake and eat it. So she wants her, you know, all the status and prestige that she gets from being married to this very significant player in Italian politics. But she also wants her famous English poet. They also kind of settle down in the palazzo in a weird ménage à trois, with Dominic shaking his head. It's a bit Nelson and the Hamiltons. Yeah, it is. And I think that's not a coincidence because this is kind of more accepted in Italy than anywhere else. There's this kind of cavaliere servente, this idea that a wife can have a kind of aristocratic, attentive servant. Companion. Companion. So this is what happens. And I think that Byron's willingness to settle down
她想鱼与熊掌兼得。她想要，你知道，作为这个意大利政坛重要人物的妻子所能获得的所有地位和声望。但她也想要她那位著名的英国诗人。他们还在宫殿里以一种奇怪的三人行方式安顿下来，多米尼克在摇头。这有点像纳尔逊和汉密尔顿夫妇。是的，确实。我认为这并非巧合，因为这种关系在意大利比在其他任何地方都更容易被接受。有一种所谓的“骑士侍从”，即妻子可以拥有一位贵族式的、体贴的仆人。伴侣。伴侣。所以这就是发生的事情。而且我认为拜伦愿意安定下来
is enhanced by his feeling that his links to England are being lost. So not only is Augusta not really writing to him anymore, Lady Melbourne has died, so he's lost that contact as well. And I think also his relations with people back in England is not helped by the fact that this is the period where he begins his greatest poem, Don Juan, which I know people these days tend not to curl up with a kind of massive epic poem. But if you curled up with Don Juan, you would be reading the most readable long poem in the whole of English. It's like a kind of 18th century novel in verse. So it describes Don Juan, Byron calls him Don Juan for the rhythm and because it's funny. Don Juan's mother is a scarcely veiled portrait of Lady Byron. So he mocks both the process of their separation. So
是因为他感到自己与英国的联系正在丧失。不仅奥古斯塔不再给他写信，墨尔本夫人也去世了，所以他也失去了那种联系。而且我认为他与英国人的关系也没有得到改善，因为这段时期他开始创作他最伟大的诗作《唐璜》，我知道现在的人们往往不会去读那种宏大的史诗。但如果你读了《唐璜》，你就会发现它是整个英语世界中最具可读性的长诗。它就像一部18世纪的诗体小说。它描述了唐璜，拜伦称他为唐璜是为了节奏感，也因为这很有趣。唐璜的母亲几乎就是拜伦夫人的写照。所以他嘲讽了他们分居的过程。所以
people who listened to the previous episode may remember Lady Byron rummaging around in his trunks and finding opium and a copy of the Marquis de Sade. So in Don Juan, Juan's mother is called Inez. For Inez called some druggists and physicians and tried to prove her loving Lord was mad. But as he had some lucid intermissions, she next decided he was only bad. So that's clearly a portrait of the whole scandal. And he mocks her by being a brain box, doesn't he? He does. A notorious couplet. But oh, ye lords of ladies intellectual, inform us truly, have they not hen-pecked you all?
听过上一集的朋友可能还记得拜伦夫人翻找他的行李箱，发现了鸦片和一本萨德侯爵的作品。所以在《唐璜》中，胡安的母亲名叫伊内兹。因为伊内兹叫来了一些药剂师和医生，试图证明她那充满爱意的丈夫疯了。但由于他还有清醒的间歇期，她后来断定他只是变坏了。所以这显然是对整个丑闻的写照。他嘲讽她是个书呆子，不是吗？是的。那句著名的双行诗。但是，哦，你们这些知识女性的领主们，请如实告诉我们，她们难道没有把你们都管得服服帖帖吗？
Okay. One for our feminist listeners to get across about there. I mean, his attitude to women, is he contemptuous women? He has a misogynist strain, but he adores them as well. I mean, you're complaining that the description of Teresa is conflicted. Yeah. I mean, okay. I can understand that he has a complicated relationship with women. He has a complicated relationship with women, I think. And predictably when Byron's friends get the beginning of Don Juan, they're appalled by it. And Murray, his publisher, is terrified of
好吧。这是留给我们女性主义听众去思考的。我的意思是，他对女性的态度，他是蔑视女性吗？他有一种厌女倾向，但他同时也崇拜她们。我的意思是，你抱怨对特蕾莎的描述是矛盾的。是的。我的意思是，好吧。我可以理解他与女性的关系很复杂。我认为他与女性的关系很复杂。不出所料，当拜伦的朋友们看到《唐璜》的开头时，他们感到震惊。他的出版商默里被
publishing it. And when he does so, eventually he does it without Byron's name on the cover. But of course, people have only to read it to know that it's Byron. And so it just adds more to Byron's selfless reputation in England. And I think Byron is quite pleased about this because, you know, on the Oscar Wilde principle that if there's one thing worse than being talked about, it's not being talked about. And I think he feels it gives him at least a kind of a hint of the glamour, the Napoleonic glamour that he'd always dreamed of. And this sense that he is slightly mouldering as an expat, I think he's regretting his exile by this point, is sharpened for him by the events that are happening in England. Because 1819, of course, is the year of Peter Loo, the Peter Loo massacre, when strikers are ridden down by the local dragoons. And it gets
出版它吓坏了。当他最终出版时，封面上没有写拜伦的名字。但当然，人们只要读一读就知道是拜伦写的。所以这只会增加拜伦在英国那声名狼藉的形象。而且我认为拜伦对此相当高兴，因为，你知道，根据奥斯卡·王尔德的原则，如果有什么比被议论更糟糕的事，那就是不被议论。而且我认为他觉得这至少给了他一种魅力，一种他一直梦寐以求的拿破仑式的魅力。而这种作为外籍人士正在逐渐腐朽的感觉，我想他此时已经后悔流亡了，这种感觉因英国发生的事件而变得更加强烈。因为1819年当然是彼得卢大屠杀发生的一年，当时罢工者被当地的龙骑兵骑马践踏。这让
Shelley very upset. He writes The Mask of Anarchy about it. And also it gets John Cam Hobhouse, Byron's oldest friend, very upset because Hobhouse by this point has become, rather to Byron's surprise and I think annoyance, a kind of a radical firebrand. And in December 1819, Hobhouse is sent to Newgate jail because he's published an incendiary pamphlet and is enshrined as a martyr for liberty among radicals. And I think Byron is really jealous. He's quite unpleasant about it, actually. Yeah, he doesn't think that his boring friend, his sidekick, is getting all the attention as the radical martyr. Exactly. It's like Sherlock Holmes being resentful of Dr. Watson solving a brilliant case.
雪莱非常不安。他为此写了《无政府的面具》。这也让拜伦最老的朋友约翰·卡姆·霍布豪斯非常不安，因为霍布豪斯此时已经变成了一个激进的煽动者，这让拜伦感到惊讶，我想也让他感到恼火。1819年12月，霍布豪斯被送进纽盖特监狱，因为他出版了一本煽动性的小册子，并被激进分子奉为自由的烈士。我想拜伦真的很嫉妒。他对此表现得相当不愉快，真的。是的，他不认为他那个无聊的朋友、他的跟班能得到作为激进烈士的所有关注。没错。这就像夏洛克·福尔摩斯对华生医生破获了一起精彩案件感到不满一样。
Right. That kind of thing. And so whether coincidentally or not, from this point on, he starts to become much more politically involved in British politics, but also in Italian politics. And this is partly prompted by the fact that in July 1820, the Pope grants a degree of separation to Count Guiccioli. So he and Teresa separate. And Teresa moves back to live with her father, Count Gamba, he's called. And Count Gamba is passionately committed to the cause of freeing Italy from Austrian rule and joining up all the disparate parts into which Italy is divided. Byron goes with Teresa and so sets up shop with
没错。就是那种感觉。所以无论是否巧合，从这一点开始，他开始更多地参与英国政治，也参与意大利政治。这在一定程度上是因为1820年7月，教皇批准了古乔利伯爵的分居请求。所以他和特蕾莎分开了。特蕾莎搬回去和她的父亲甘巴伯爵住在一起。甘巴伯爵热衷于将意大利从奥地利统治下解放出来，并将意大利分裂的各个部分统一起来的事业。拜伦跟随特蕾莎，于是和
Count Gamba. Count Gamba and his son Pietro are part of this kind of secret society that is committed to Italian liberty, the Carbonari. And early in 1823, there's an abortive revolution in which the Carbonari evolved. Byron is involved very, very tangentially. The revolution fails. And as a result of this, the Gambas are sent into exile. And again, Byron goes with them and he has to leave Ravenna and he leaves Allegra behind in a convent. He's decided that he wants Allegra brought up as a Catholic. Byron then heads off to Pisa, which is in Tuscany with its leaning tower. And there he is joined again by the Shelleys who've been in Italy all this time. And when Shelley meets Byron this time, he's relieved
甘巴伯爵一起安顿下来。甘巴伯爵和他的儿子彼得罗是致力于意大利自由的秘密组织“烧炭党”的成员。1823年初，发生了一场流产的革命，烧炭党参与其中。拜伦非常非常边缘地参与了。革命失败了。结果，甘巴一家被流放。拜伦再次跟随他们，他不得不离开拉文纳，把阿莱格拉留在了修道院。他决定让阿莱格拉接受天主教教育。拜伦随后前往比萨，也就是托斯卡纳那个有斜塔的地方。在那里，他再次与一直待在意大利的雪莱一家会合。当雪莱这次见到拜伦时，他感到很欣慰，
to find that Byron is no longer fat and bloated and dissipated, but seems much more committed both to poetry and to politics. And again, this kind of paradox, Dominic. Shelley is simultaneously relieved by this, full of admiration for Byron, but also full of a resentment that almost, I think, borders on hatred. And so Shelley writes of Byron, I despair of rivaling him as well as I may, and there is no other with whom it is worth contending. But the two poets, they team up, the various other English radicals come out to join them, and they produce a newspaper called The Liberal, which is to be published in England. And the first edition
发现拜伦不再肥胖、臃肿和放荡，而是似乎更致力于诗歌和政治。又是这种悖论，多米尼克。雪莱对此感到欣慰，对拜伦充满钦佩，但也充满了几乎让我觉得近乎仇恨的怨恨。所以雪莱写道，我绝望于能与他匹敌，也没有其他人值得与之竞争。但这两位诗人联手了，其他各种英国激进分子也加入进来，他们创办了一份名为《自由主义者》的报纸，准备在英国出版。第一期
includes a brilliant satire by Byron on the recent death of George III, which is so rude that it gets the guy back in England who has published it. He goes on trial. Byron has to keep him in jail when he gets sentenced. Byron is back on the public stage in England, not just as a figure of satanic notoriety, but now as a figure of political notoriety. So this is all seems to be kicking off, but then two disasters. The first is that news reaches Byron, Shelley, Mary Shelley, and in due course, Claire Claremont,
收录了拜伦对乔治三世最近去世的一篇精彩讽刺文章，文章内容非常粗鲁，以至于在英国出版这篇文章的人被送上了法庭。拜伦不得不在他被判刑时供养他。拜伦重新回到了英国的公共舞台上，不仅作为一个撒旦般的恶名人物，现在更作为一个政治恶名人物。所以这一切似乎都要开始了，但随后发生了两场灾难。第一场是拜伦、雪莱、玛丽·雪莱，以及后来的克莱尔·克莱蒙特收到了消息，
that Allegra has died in her convent, very young. Oh no. So very tragic. Byron has lost his, you know, his second daughter. And then Byron, Shelley, Therese's brother, Pietro, various other members of their radical set, they're embroiled in a brawl with various dragoons outside Pisa. And by this point, the Tuscan authorities are fed up with them. They get expelled. So May 1822, Byron is on the road again. And he goes to Livorno, what the English call Leghorn, and he rents a villa there with views over the sea. And Byron always loves the sea. It always makes him happy because, of course, you know, he is lame, but the sea provides him with opportunities to swim. Yes, of course.
阿莱格拉在修道院去世了，年纪很小。哦，不。太悲惨了。拜伦失去了他的，你知道，他的第二个女儿。然后拜伦、雪莱、特蕾莎的兄弟彼得罗，以及他们激进圈子里的其他成员，在比萨外与几名龙骑兵发生了争执。此时，托斯卡纳当局已经受够了他们。他们被驱逐了。所以1822年5月，拜伦又上路了。他去了利沃诺，英国人称之为莱格霍恩，并在那里租了一栋可以看到海景的别墅。拜伦一直热爱大海。大海总是让他快乐，因为，当然，你知道，他是个跛子，但大海为他提供了游泳的机会。是的，当然。
In the sea, Byron is mobile. He's a very strong swimmer. Unlike Shelley, of course, who cannot swim. And he and Shelley had both a few months earlier commissioned boats. So Byron had commissioned a three-masted kind of sailing ship, which he called the Bolivar Dominic. And I know you love a South American hero of liberation, don't you? Yeah, Simon Bolivar. Byron, I think at this point, is seriously thinking maybe of going to South America.
在海里，拜伦是灵活的。他是一个非常强壮的游泳者。不像雪莱，当然，他不会游泳。他和雪莱都在几个月前订购了船只。所以拜伦订购了一艘三桅帆船，他称之为“玻利瓦尔号”，多米尼克。我知道你喜欢南美解放英雄，对吧？是的，西蒙·玻利瓦尔。我想拜伦此时正在认真考虑去南美。
He's kind of enthused by stories of Bolivar or indeed even to North America, because at this point, the American Mediterranean fleet sails into Leghorn and they invite Byron down and they kind of toast him. And Byron is incredibly flattered by this. So he is seriously thinking about going to America. But then disaster. So Shelley's boat is called the Ariel, even though, again, kind of playing on Shelley's resentment and sense of inferiority to Byron, Shelley and Byron had initially bought this together and Byron had asked it to be called the Don Juan. Oh, to rub it in.
他被玻利瓦尔的故事所鼓舞，甚至考虑去北美，因为此时，美国地中海舰队驶入莱格霍恩，他们邀请拜伦上船，并为他祝酒。拜伦对此感到受宠若惊。所以他正在认真考虑去美国。但随后灾难降临了。雪莱的船叫“爱丽儿号”，尽管，同样，这有点利用了雪莱对拜伦的怨恨和自卑感，雪莱和拜伦最初是一起买的，拜伦曾要求把它命名为“唐璜号”。哦，真是火上浇油。
Yeah, it hasn't been painted out. So Shelley's boat, you know, it's called the Don Juan, even though he wants to call it the Ariel. Both boats are delivered to the respective owners in June and they use them. And then on the 13th of July, Teresa and Byron in their house above Leghorn, they hear the kind of the crunching on gravel of the wheels of a carriage and there's knocking at the door. And there at the door is a pale faced Mary Shelley, white as marble, Teresa will later write. And Mary says, have you any news of Shelley? And she tells Byron
是的，名字还没被漆掉。所以雪莱的船，你知道，它叫“唐璜号”，尽管他想叫它“爱丽儿号”。两艘船都在6月交付给了各自的主人，他们也使用了它们。然后在7月13日，特蕾莎和拜伦在莱格霍恩上方的房子里，听到马车轮子在砾石上碾压的声音，接着是敲门声。门口站着脸色苍白的玛丽·雪莱，特蕾莎后来写道，她白得像大理石一样。玛丽问，你有雪莱的消息吗？她告诉拜伦
that Shelley had gone out on the 8th of July. So that's five days before on the aerial and hasn't been seen since. Yeah. Five days has been gone. Yeah. And, and, you know, to reiterate, Shelley doesn't swim. And so Byron joins the search, they go up and down the coast and on the 18th of July. So that's 10 days after he'd vanished, the body of Shelley and two people who'd been with him on the boat are of July, so that's 10 days after he'd vanished, the body of Shelley and two people who'd been with him on the boat are found. And Shelley has to be recognised by his clothing because his face has been eaten by crabs. And it's agreed that Shelley as an atheist, as a pagan,
雪莱在7月8日出海了。也就是五天前，坐的是“爱丽儿号”，从那以后就没再露面。是的。已经失踪五天了。是的。而且，你知道，重申一下，雪莱不会游泳。所以拜伦加入了搜寻，他们在海岸上来回寻找，在7月18日。也就是他失踪10天后，雪莱和船上另外两个人的尸体被发现了。雪莱必须通过他的衣服来辨认，因为他的脸已经被螃蟹吃掉了。大家一致认为，雪莱作为一个无神论者，作为一个异教徒，
should be cremated on the beach, but it takes them a month to get the permits for this. And so Shelley's body and the bodies of the others are buried in quicklime. And permission comes through on the 16th of August. They go into the quicklime, dig up the various bodies. They find Shelley's skull. Byron had wanted to keep Shelley's skull as a memento. Would you keep my skull, Tom? Yeah, I think I would.
应该在海滩上火化，但他们花了一个月才拿到许可证。所以雪莱和其他人的尸体被埋在生石灰里。8月16日获得了许可。他们进入生石灰坑，挖出各种尸体。他们发现了雪莱的头骨。拜伦曾想把雪莱的头骨留作纪念。你会留着我的头骨吗，汤姆？是的，我想我会的。
Would you? Well, I would if it wasn't cracked by a spade in the quicklime in which your skull had been preserved, which is what happens to Shelleys. So it gets shattered. So Byron decides he won't keep it. And so the whole lot gets burned on the beach. And Byron can't bear really to watch it because, of course, the corpse is a horrid kind of green indigo colour.
你会吗？嗯，如果它没有被保存你头骨的生石灰坑里的铲子敲碎的话，我会的，而雪莱的头骨就是这样。所以它碎了。于是拜伦决定不留着它了。所以所有的东西都在海滩上烧掉了。拜伦真的无法忍受观看，因为，当然，尸体呈现出一种可怕的绿色靛蓝色。
Shelley's barely recognisable. Yeah, you're not selling it. The flesh, the bones start to turn to ashes and Byron doesn't stay. He goes out, wades out into the sea, swims out to the Bolivar, which is a mile and a half offshore to cleanse himself. With Shelley's death, the whole kind of circle of radicals that had been gathered around Byron and Shelley starts to split up. And Byron feels increasingly isolated, increasingly restive, I think, and increasingly alert to events in Greece. For two years there, the Greeks have been fighting a war of independence.
雪莱几乎无法辨认。是的，你这描述可真不吸引人。血肉和骨头开始化为灰烬，拜伦没有留下。他走出去，涉水进入大海，游向离岸一英里半的“玻利瓦尔号”来清洗自己。随着雪莱的去世，聚集在拜伦和雪莱周围的整个激进分子圈子开始分裂。拜伦感到越来越孤立，越来越焦躁，我想，也越来越关注希腊发生的事件。两年来，希腊人一直在进行独立战争。
It had broken out in the Peloponnese, so that's the southern bit of Greece. Byron becomes increasingly obsessed by it. I think this is partly because the dream of Italian liberty is dead. All his attempts to work with that have failed, but also I think just because he's bored. So Pietro Gamba, Therese's brother, who's become very close to Byron by this point, he says of Byron that he often felt the want of some other occupation than that of writing. So again, it's that idea that Byron had always had, that writing poetry somehow isn't worthy of him. And meanwhile, without consulting Byron, Hobhouse, who's poetry somehow isn't worthy of him. And meanwhile, without consulting Byron, Hobhouse, who's been released by this point from Newgate and is
它在伯罗奔尼撒半岛爆发，也就是希腊的南部地区。拜伦对此越来越着迷。我想这部分是因为意大利自由的梦想已经破灭。他所有与之合作的尝试都失败了，但也因为他觉得无聊。所以特蕾莎的兄弟彼得罗·甘巴，此时已经和拜伦非常亲近了，他说拜伦经常感到除了写作之外还需要做点别的事情。所以，这又是拜伦一直以来的那种想法，即写诗在某种程度上配不上他。与此同时，在没有咨询拜伦的情况下，霍布豪斯，此时已经从纽盖特监狱获释，并且
working with the London Greek Committee, so that's the committee that is kind of raising funds for the Greek rebels back in England. He suggests to the London Greek Committee that they should approach Byron, and they do so, and Byron is wildly enthusiastic. So this is the first time, isn't it, Tom, that a foreign insurgency has really seized the imagination of the kind of fashionable elites of Europe. Yeah. So you know how the people do now. People get very excited about foreign causes and they go on demonstrations. Yeah, Ukraine would be the example. Yeah, Ukraine or whatever it might be. But this is the first time really it's happened and become a massive kind of cultural phenomenon, I know we shall never see each other again. He feels at last, this is what he's been waiting for. Right from the time he first went to Greece, he has dreamed of playing the part
正在与伦敦希腊委员会合作，也就是那个在英国为希腊叛军筹集资金的委员会。他建议伦敦希腊委员会应该接触拜伦，他们确实这么做了，拜伦非常热情。所以这是第一次，不是吗，汤姆，一场外国叛乱真正抓住了欧洲时尚精英的想象力。是的。所以你知道现在的人们是怎么做的。人们对外国事业感到非常兴奋，他们去参加示威。是的，乌克兰就是一个例子。是的，乌克兰或其他什么。但这确实是第一次发生这种情况，并成为一种巨大的文化现象，我知道我们再也见不到彼此了。他终于感到，这就是他一直在等待的。从他第一次去希腊的时候起，他就梦想着扮演
of a Napoleon and to do it in the cause of Greek freedom. I mean, it's kind of perfect. And so his plans for Greece are a mix of the practical. So he orders gunpowder. He liquidates as many assets as he can in England to raise liquid funds. But also, of course, the completely romantic. So inevitably, he buys himself Pietro Gamba, Teresa's sister, who's going to accompany him, various other people. Brilliant outfits. So tremendous uniforms, complete with kind of plumed helmets that are decorated with
拿破仑的角色，并为希腊自由的事业而战。我的意思是，这简直太完美了。所以他为希腊制定的计划是实用主义的结合。他订购了火药。他清算了他在英国能清算的所有资产以筹集流动资金。但当然，也完全是浪漫主义的。所以不可避免地，他为自己，为彼得罗·甘巴，为特蕾莎的妹妹，以及其他陪同他的人买了装备。华丽的服装。所以非常棒的制服，配上装饰着
the goddess Athena on the front. So very, very Byron. And they set out for Greece on the 13th of July, 1823. And he sails initially to Cephalonia, which is part of the Ionian Islands. So those islands that are on the west coast of Greece. And there he plays basically an ambassadorial role. So he is liaising between London and the rebels who are holed up in a town called Missolonghi, which is kind of set amid lagoons on mainland Greece and which Byron and Hobhouse had passed by ship on their original trip.
正面女神雅典娜的羽毛头盔。所以非常非常拜伦。他们于1823年7月13日出发前往希腊。他最初航行到凯法利尼亚岛，那是爱奥尼亚群岛的一部分。也就是希腊西海岸的那些岛屿。在那里，他基本上扮演了一个大使的角色。所以他在伦敦和躲在迈索隆吉镇的叛军之间进行联络，迈索隆吉位于希腊大陆的泻湖之中，拜伦和霍布豪斯在最初的旅行中曾乘船经过那里。
It's not far from Patras, is it? Yeah. He's also liaising between the Greeks and London with the British military representative there, who is a guy called Napier, who in due course will go on to conquer Sindh in India and make the famous pun, Bacavi, I have sinned. And he has a statue in Trafalgar Square. Trafalgar Square, yeah. And Napier, like Byron, is very, very Phil Hellenic, but is not a free agent in the way that Byron is, because he's under British military authority and Britain ostensibly is neutral in the
离帕特雷不远，对吧？是的。他还在希腊人和伦敦之间与那里的英国军事代表进行联络，那个人叫纳皮尔，他后来征服了印度的信德省，并说了那句著名的双关语，“我犯罪了”（Bacavi, I have sinned）。他在特拉法尔加广场有一座雕像。特拉法尔加广场，是的。纳皮尔和拜伦一样，非常非常亲希腊，但并不像拜伦那样是一个自由人，因为他受英国军事当局的管辖，而英国表面上在
conflict. But Byron absolutely isn't. He continues to try and raise as much money as he can. So we mentioned ages back, it seems now, that Byron's own various coal mines around Rochdale and that the wicked Lord had rented them out. Byron's managed to get them back, but he now sells all of them to raise money for the Greeks. And he is also writing letters to various people in Britain, across Europe, kind of trying to raise the profile of the Greek rebellion. So he really is putting his shoulder to the wheel. And essentially he is the guy who is by this stage bankrolling the entire Greek revolution, which otherwise would have very few funds. So by December 1823, a crisis point is approaching Missolonghi because it's being both besieged
冲突中保持中立。但拜伦绝对不是。他继续试图筹集尽可能多的资金。所以我们很久以前提到过，拜伦自己在罗奇代尔周围的各种煤矿，那个邪恶的勋爵把它们租出去了。拜伦设法把它们拿了回来，但他现在把它们全部卖掉以筹集资金给希腊人。他还给英国和欧洲各地的各种人写信，试图提高希腊叛乱的知名度。所以他确实是在全力以赴。基本上，他就是那个阶段为整个希腊革命提供资金的人，否则希腊革命将几乎没有资金。所以到1823年12月，迈索隆吉正面临危机，因为它正受到
by land and blockaded by sea. And the Greek leaders write to Byron and say, look, Missolonghi is going to fall unless you come here because you coming here will raise the profile across Europe and guarantee us more support. And they write to him and say, you will be received here as a saviour. Be assured, my Lord, that it depends only on yourself to secure the destiny of Greece. This had never been what the London Greek Committee had envisaged. They had never suggested that Byron actually go into the conflict zone. But Byron can't resist the opportunity. And so he has one last go at raising all the credit he can. He knows that he needs to fund the Greek defence,
陆路围困和海路封锁。希腊领导人写信给拜伦说，看，迈索隆吉如果不来人就要陷落了，因为你的到来将提高整个欧洲的知名度，并保证我们获得更多的支持。他们写信给他说，你在这里将受到救世主般的欢迎。请放心，勋爵，希腊的命运只取决于你自己。这从来不是伦敦希腊委员会所设想的。他们从未建议拜伦真正进入冲突地区。但拜伦无法抗拒这个机会。所以他最后一次尝试筹集他能筹集到的所有信贷。他知道他需要资助希腊的防御，
particularly the Navy, the Greek fleet, because they haven't been paid for months and months and months. And so on the 29th of December, he and Pietro Gamba set sail for Missolonghi. And Byron writes, I am passing the Rubicon. Recollect that for God's sake and the sake of Greece. So they arrive at Missolonghi having kind of woven in between the Turkish blockade on the 4th of January, 1824, and they get the hero's welcome. All the Greek fighters are drawn up. The soldiers give him a salute. The Greek fleet gives him a kind of a naval salute as well. People in the fleet are particularly enthusiastic because, of course,
特别是海军，希腊舰队，因为他们已经好几个月没有领到工资了。所以12月29日，他和彼得罗·甘巴启航前往迈索隆吉。拜伦写道，我正在跨越卢比孔河。为了上帝的缘故，为了希腊的缘故，记住这一点。所以他们在1824年1月4日，在土耳其封锁线之间穿梭后抵达迈索隆吉，并受到了英雄般的欢迎。所有的希腊战士都列队站好。士兵们向他敬礼。希腊舰队也向他致以海军礼。舰队里的人特别热情，因为，当然，
Byron has brought their wages with him. And everyone in the town, they're all dressed up in traditional Greek costume. They're all firing their guns and toasting him with their etzina and all the kind of stuff. But unfortunately, this is as good as it gets because the whole situation is grim. They're surrounded by lagoons. There's no opportunities for kind of heroic combat. There's just hunger and rain, endless, endless rain. And Byron writes, the dykes of Holland when broken down are the deserts of Arabia for dryness in comparison. And so there are mosquitoes, it's incredibly unhealthy, and Byron falls sick. And on the 22nd of January, it's his 36th birthday, and he writes an incredibly
拜伦带来了他们的工资。镇上的每个人都穿着传统的希腊服装。他们都在鸣枪，用他们的齐普罗酒为他祝酒，诸如此类。但不幸的是，这就是最好的情况了，因为整个局势很严峻。他们被泻湖包围。没有英雄战斗的机会。只有饥饿和雨，没完没了的雨。拜伦写道，荷兰的堤坝决堤时，与这里的干燥相比，简直就是阿拉伯沙漠。所以有蚊子，环境极其不健康，拜伦病倒了。1月22日，是他36岁生日，他写了一首极其
despondent poem. And it's despondent about the fact that he is old and no longer attractive to the kind of young Greek boys who back when he had been, you know, 19 or 20, he had been very attractive to. And he's brought a page boy with him, a Greek page boy. And the Greek page boy makes it absolutely clear that he has no interest in Byron at all. He looks on Byron as an old man. Byron is a source of flashy uniforms and money, but nothing else. And so Byron writes this very sad poem. It is time this heart should be unmoved since others it has ceased to move. Yet though I cannot be beloved, still let me love. And he's thinking there both of, I think, Augusta and Teresa and of Greece. And on the 15th of February, he has a massive seizure. He's urged
沮丧的诗。他沮丧是因为他老了，不再吸引那些在他19或20岁时曾非常吸引他的年轻希腊男孩了。他带了一个侍童，一个希腊侍童。那个希腊侍童明确表示他对拜伦一点兴趣都没有。他把拜伦看作一个老人。拜伦只是华丽制服和金钱的来源，除此之外什么都不是。所以拜伦写了这首非常悲伤的诗。是时候让这颗心不再动摇了，因为它已不再能打动别人。然而，虽然我不能被爱，但请让我继续去爱。他在这里想到的，我想，既有奥古斯塔和特蕾莎，也有希腊。2月15日，他发生了严重的癫痫。他被
by his doctors and his friends to leave Missolonghi, but he refuses. The seizure like a fit, Tom? Yeah, a fit. And people despair of his life, but he refuses to go. He says, it is proper that I remain in Greece and it were better to die doing something than nothing. But in fact, you know, he's not going to do something because he is getting more and more sick. And by mid-April, he is confined to his bed. On the 15th of April, he's bled. On the 18th of April, he's incoherent. He's recorded
医生和朋友们敦促离开迈索隆吉，但他拒绝了。癫痫就像发作一样，汤姆？是的，发作。人们对他的生命感到绝望，但他拒绝离开。他说，我留在希腊是恰当的，死在做某事上总比什么都不做要好。但事实上，你知道，他什么也做不了，因为他病得越来越重。到4月中旬，他被限制在床上。4月15日，他被放血。4月18日，他语无伦次。据记录，他
muttering various names, Augusta, Ada, Hobhouse. Doesn't seem to have mentioned his wife's name. On the 19th of April, he's unconscious. And then at 6.15 that evening, on the 19th of April, he's unconscious. And then at 6.15 that evening on the 19th of April, the sun is setting, storm clouds are building up, thunder starts to roll. Byron opens his eyes, closed them, and Fletcher, his manservant, who you remember from the first episode had hated the toilets and the drains of Greece, but has gone back nevertheless to attend to Byron. Fletcher cries out, oh my God, I fear his lordship is gone. And he is, Byron is dead. And at dawn the next day, Missolonghi echoes to the gums as they issue a farewell salute. So Tom, what did he die of? What killed him?
喃喃自语着各种名字，奥古斯塔，艾达，霍布豪斯。似乎没有提到他妻子的名字。4月19日，他昏迷了。然后在4月19日那天傍晚6点15分，太阳正在下山，风暴云正在聚集，雷声开始滚动。拜伦睁开眼睛，闭上眼睛，他的男仆弗莱彻，你还记得第一集里他讨厌希腊的厕所和下水道，但尽管如此还是回来照顾拜伦。弗莱彻大喊，哦，上帝，我恐怕勋爵已经走了。他确实走了，拜伦死了。第二天黎明，迈索隆吉回荡着枪声，他们发出了告别礼。所以汤姆，他是死于什么？什么杀了他？
It's not entirely clear, probably kind of malaria. Okay. The mosquitoes and the bad conditions and stuff yeah it's it's just disease ridden yeah i mean byron has lived hard so they do an autopsy on him and the sutures of his skull are found to have fused together and apparently this is a mark of immense old age so there's a sense of a man who, you know, in his 36 years has compressed a hundred years of experience and kind of sensation. And of course, those experiences have made him famous and loved and have made him notorious and feared. And when his body comes back to England, Hobhouse applies for him to be buried in westminster abbey at poet's corner and the abbey say no he's evil we can't have that kind of person buried in
不太清楚，可能是某种疟疾。好吧。蚊子和恶劣的环境等等，是的，这简直是疾病缠身。我的意思是，拜伦生活得很艰苦，所以他们对他进行了尸检，发现他头骨的缝合线已经融合在一起了，显然这是极度衰老的标志。所以有一种感觉，一个在36年里压缩了100年经历和感觉的人。当然，这些经历让他出名、被爱，也让他声名狼藉、令人恐惧。当他的尸体回到英国时，霍布豪斯申请将他葬在威斯敏斯特教堂的诗人角，但教堂说不，他是邪恶的，我们不能让那种人葬在
westminster abbey and hobhouse has already persuaded murray to burn byron's memoirs which byron had given for safekeeping to tom mo, his friend and fellow poet, and asked him to publish them. And the entire manuscript of his memoirs go up in flames. And as a Byron fan yourself, Tom, you must find that absolutely gutting. Agony. Yeah, complete agony. And you kind of wonder, well, what was in them? I mean, who knows? But you also, you know, you have this reaction of kind of love and shock. So we began this series with the young Tennyson, 15 year old Tennyson going up onto the moors. That's right. Byron is dead. Crying out, Byron is dead. So just to finish this by saying what happens to the people that Byron leaves behind, Hobhouse goes on to become a very distinguished Whig politician,
威斯敏斯特教堂。霍布豪斯已经说服默里烧毁了拜伦的回忆录，拜伦曾把这些回忆录交给他的朋友兼诗人汤姆·摩尔保管，并请他出版。回忆录的全部手稿付之一炬。作为拜伦的粉丝，汤姆，你一定觉得这太令人心碎了。痛苦。是的，完全的痛苦。你会想，里面写了什么？我的意思是，谁知道呢？但你也会，你知道，有一种爱和震惊的反应。所以我们以年轻的丁尼生开始了这个系列，15岁的丁尼生走上荒原。没错。拜伦死了。大喊，拜伦死了。所以最后说一下拜伦身后的人发生了什么，霍布豪斯后来成为了一位非常杰出的辉格党政治家，
very eminent. Augusta, she dies in 1851, terribly in debt. So like her father, she's terrible with money and is always catching people for loans. Lady Byron dies in 1860. There's a photograph of her. She looks kind of very intimidating. She does. She looks terrifying in that photo. She has devoted her life to good, anti-slavery campaigner, prison reformer, but she has also been a kind of moral succubus on poor Augusta. The pair of them are kind of locked in this terrible embrace for the rest of their lives. And Ada, as you said, is now the toast of female scientific engagement. So, you know, women in STEM, Ada Lovelace is the...
非常显赫。奥古斯塔，她死于1851年，负债累累。所以像她父亲一样，她不善理财，总是找人借钱。拜伦夫人死于1860年。有一张她的照片。她看起来非常令人生畏。是的。在那张照片里她看起来很可怕。她把一生都奉献给了善事，反奴隶制运动，监狱改革，但她也一直是可怜的奥古斯塔身上的某种道德吸血鬼。她们两人在余生中都被锁在这种可怕的拥抱中。而艾达，正如你所说，现在是女性科学参与的宠儿。所以，你知道，STEM领域的女性，艾达·洛夫莱斯是……
Yeah, she's the great pinup girl. But Ada is also a terrible gambler. You know, she applies her mathematical abilities to trying to work out the odds. And she ends up dead like her father at the age of 36. Right. I'm not very clued up on Ada Lovelace's career. I didn't realise she died so young. Yeah, she did.
是的，她是伟大的海报女郎。但艾达也是一个可怕的赌徒。你知道，她运用她的数学能力试图算出赔率。她最终像她父亲一样在36岁时去世了。好吧。我对艾达·洛夫莱斯的职业生涯不太了解。我没意识到她死得这么早。是的，她确实死了。
So that basically is Byron, who I think is a remarkable figure and a fascinating figure. And his story, I mean, you can see why so many biographies have been written of him and why he remains a subject of such interest right the way to the present day. Sexual scandal, celebrity, literary culture, nationalism, political radicalism. There's so much there, isn't there, Tom? There really is. Yeah. There are a few lives that contain so many different and exciting strands. Yeah. And this is the 200th anniversary of his death. Previous week, if you're listening to this as it comes out, would it be self-indulgent to finish just with
所以这就是拜伦，我认为他是一个非凡的人物，一个迷人的人物。他的故事，我的意思是，你可以看出为什么有这么多关于他的传记，为什么直到今天他仍然是一个如此令人感兴趣的主题。性丑闻、名人、文学文化、民族主义、政治激进主义。那里有很多东西，不是吗，汤姆？确实如此。是的。很少有生命包含这么多不同且令人兴奋的线索。是的。这是他逝世200周年。上周，如果你在它发布时听这个，以
a stanza from Childe Harold's Pilgrimage? When you said self-indulgent, I feared you were going to end a podcast about Lord Byron by reading some of your own poetry. No, no. So this is from Childe Harold's Pilgrimage. It's from the last section that he wrote, account of his travels across Italy. But I have lived and have not lived in vain.
《恰尔德·哈罗德游记》中的一节结束是否会显得自我放纵？当你提到自我放纵时，我担心你会以朗读你自己的诗歌来结束关于拜伦勋爵的播客。不，不。所以这是来自《恰尔德·哈罗德游记》。这是他写的最后一部分，关于他穿越意大利的旅行。但我活过，并没有白活。
My mind may lose its force, my blood its fire, and my frame perish even in conquering pain. But there is that within me which shall tire, torture and time and breathe when I expire.
我的思想可能会失去力量，我的血液可能会失去火焰，我的躯体甚至会在征服痛苦中毁灭。但我的内心深处有某种东西，它将超越
Something unearthly which they deem not of, like the remembered tone of a mute liar shall on their softened spirits sink and move in hearts all rocky now the late remorse of love. Very good
折磨和时间，并在我逝去后依然呼吸。某种超凡脱俗的东西，他们无法理解，就像那被记住的无声竖琴的音调，将沉入他们柔软的精神中，并在现在坚硬的心中移动，那是迟来的爱的悔恨。非常好。
Bye bye I'm Marina Hyde and I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com.
再见，我是玛丽娜·海德，我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们一起主持《剩下的就是娱乐》。这是你每周的娱乐新闻、评论、一点点演艺圈八卦的来源。在我们的问答环节，我们揭开娱乐的面纱，告诉你它是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了我们的会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、额外剧集和提前获得现场门票，请前往therestisentertainment.com。
That's therestisentertainment.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
那是therestisentertainment.com。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。